as many of the world's ultra wealthy
continue to grow their fortunes
mackenzie scott is giving hers away at a
faster rate than any billionaire in
modern history scott who is the ex-wife
of amazon founder jeff bezos is worth an
estimated 43.6 billion dollars that's a
drop of 9.4 billion or 18 percent from
her valuation last year
scott has promised to give away a
majority of her wealth which was
acquired in a 2019 divorce settlement
with bezos this pledge appears to be the
biggest factor behind her portfolio
value dropping
she has given away 12.5 billion dollars
to more than 1 250 organizations in less
than two years
this already has her ranked fifth on
forbes 2022 list of biggest lifetime
givers behind bill and melinda gates and
michael bloomberg who have been giving
away money for decades
scott has given to both small grassroots
organizations and large established
non-profits for a number of causes
including gender equity racial justice
reproductive rights and the arts once
the donations are finalized the
organizations can spend them however
they see fit her single largest donation
to date was this year to habitat for
humanity for 436 million dollars she
also made a big donation in 2022 to the
boys and girls club of america and
planned parenthood despite scott's
generosity she's still the fourth
richest woman in the world according to
forbes calculations this puts her behind
l'oreal air francoise bettencourt myers
walmart heir alice walton and koch
industries air julia coke
[Music]